What we have to do is, I needed to change make password hash
a little bit to take in a salt parameter. because we don't want to
make a new salt every time, we only want to make a new salt
when we're making a new password hash. But if we want to verify our password
hash, we want to pass in salt as a default parameter. Or, salt, or
pass in salt as a parameter. So, what I do is, I pull salt
out of the h by splitting on a comma and taking the the
second part which is the salt and then I pass that into my function.
Now, you could have also implemented this by just copying this
line into valid PW, which I guess this should have said.
May need, but it's always better if you can reuse a
function like this, so you don't have to you know, if
you want to change the logic here, you don't have to change
everything here. Let's go ahead and give this a run. You
can see it says true. And if we add an extra
print statement here, print h. And now we give this a run.
We should see our what would store on the database. Here we go, there's a
hash, there's a salt. And we can see that it matched. And if we were
to run this again we'd see that we get a different hash and salt but
it still matches. So, pretty cool, huh?
Let's discuss one more thing about password hashing.